>> PRESIDENT BIDEN PATTING
HIMSELF ON THE BACK AFTER JOBS
ADDED.
>> NONE OF THIS HAPPENED BY
ACCIDENT.
IT'S A DIRECT RESULT OF THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN.
THE LAST TIME THE ECONOMY GREW
AT THIS RATE WAS IN 1984 AND
RONALD REAGAN SAID IT'S MORNING
IN AMERICA.
IT'S CLOSE TO AFTERNOON HERE AND
THE SUN IS COMING OUT.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE IS GETTING
MOCKED FOR A CORNY SOCIAL MEDIA
POST BRAGGING ABOUT HOW
AMERICANS WILL SAVE 16 CENTS ON
FOOD AT THE 4th OF JULY AND
BIDEN WAS IN NO MOOD TO TAKE
TOUGH QUESTIONS HEADING INTO THE
HOLIDAY WEEKEND.
>> I WANT TO TALK ABOUT HAPPY
THINGS, MAN.
YOU ARE ASKING ME QUESTIONS I
WILL ANSWER NEXT WEEK.
THIS IS A HOLIDAY WEEKEND.
I WILL CELEBRATE IT.
GREAT THINGS ARE HAPPENING.
COVID-19 DEATHS ARE DOWN 90% AND
WAGES ARE UP.
WE ARE BRINGING TROOPS ONLY.
>> WILL, DON'T YOU DARE ASK
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT ABOUT
AFGHANISTAN AS HE IS HEADED TO
A BARBECUE.
THAT IS UNACCEPTABLE.
>> HE ONLY WANTS TO TALK ABOUT
HAPPY THINGS.
IT'S LATE IN THE AFTERNOON SO
IT'S DINNERTIME FOR UNCLE JOE.
TIME TO RETIRE AND THINK ABOUT
HAPPY THINGS.
ONE THING I LIKE ABOUT THIS PAST
YEAR, WHEN YOU SAID THE ECONOMY
IS GROWING AT A RECORD RATE.
IT WAS SHUT DOWN!
IT WAS AT A GRINDING HALT.
IT WILL PICK UP STEAM COMING
BACK FROM A TOTAL STOP.
YOU COULD TAKE A LIBERAL AND
CONSERVATIVE AND SAY HOW DO THE
IDEAS PLAY OUT OVER DECADES?
NOT THIS YEAR.
WE HAVE SEEN LOCKDOWNS WORKED
AND HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
STRUNG OUT OVER YEARS WORKED.
WE HAVE SEEN LIBERAL POLICIES
PLAY OUT AND IT'S A RESOUNDING
FAILURE RATE.
JOE BIDEN'S POLICY AND
LOCKDOWNS, WE HAVE REAL WORLD
EVIDENCE.
THESE ARE FAILURES.
LOOK AT THE STATES THAT CAME
BACK TO NORM.
12 ARE RED STATES THAT EMBODY
OPEN POLICIES WITH THE ECONOMY.
WE CAN SEE THE WORLD AROUND HUS.
>> JESSICA, I FEEL LIKE WILL WAS
TALKING TO YOU THAT WHOLE TIME.
>> WE WERE HAVING A PRIVATE
MOMENT.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> THAT'S THE BRAVEST MAN ON FOX
NEWS.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> THERE WAS A LOT OF SENSE TO
WHAT WILL WAS TALKING ABOUT.
EVERY MONTH WE GET MORE
INFORMATION.
STARTED WITH THE KICK OFF OF THE
PANDEMIC.
WE HAD PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES
SAYING NO MASKS AND THEN WE GOT
MORE INFORMATION AND IT'S
AIRBORNE.
THERE ARE POPULATION ISSUES FOR
BLUE STATES.
IT'S DIFFERENT TO MANAGE THAT.
WE CAN'T SPREAD OUT HERE.
I CAN'T BE AWAY FROM MY
NEIGHBOR.
IF I LIVE IN A SPARSELY
POPULATED RED STATES I COULD DO.
THAT YOU NEED TO PAY ATTENTION
TO THE RISE IN COVID INFECTION
RATES GOING UP IN RED STATES AND
WE HAVE A VACCINATION PROBLEM IN
THOSE STATES.
WITH THE DELTA VARIANT COMING
WHICH IS NOT MORE DEADLY BUT
MORE TRANSMISSIBLE THAT'S ON OUR
RADAR.
EVERYONE IN THE HOSPITAL RIGHT
NOW WITH COVID IS NOT
VACCINATED.
EVERYONE SHOULD GET VACCINATED.
TAKING A VICTORY LAP ON 850,000
JOBS, THE MOST OF ANY PRESIDENCY
ON RECORD.
WE WENT THROUGH A DEPRESSION.
OBAMA INHERITED A BUM DEAL.
THIS IS MORE THAN PRE-PANDEMIC
LEVELS.
>> THOSE NUMBERS INCLUDE
UNEMPLOYMENT RISING SO THERE IS
A BROKENNESS TO THE SYSTEM.
ENLIGHTEN US TO THE REAL NUMBERS
WE SHOULD BE REMINDED ABOUT.
>> INSTEAD OF WORKERS COMPETING
WITH EACH OTHER FOR JOBS
EMPLOYERS ARE COMPETING WITH
EACH OTHER TO ATTRACT WORKERS.
THE GOVERNMENT IS PAYING $300
A WEEK EXTRA FOR PEOPLE TO STAY
ON.
YOU.
-- ON UNEMPLOYMENT.
YOU HAVE A RECORD NUMBER OF JOB
OPENINGS.
THE JOB MARKET WOULD BE GROWING
MUCH FASTER IF THIS EXTRA $300
DID NOT EXIST FOR THE
UNEMPLOYED.
THERE IS A SCARSITY OF WORKERS.
PEOPLE WILL TRY TO FILL UP THEIR
CARS OVER THE WEEKEND AND THERE
WILL BE GAS STATIONS THAT DON'T
HAVE GAS BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH TRUCKERS LICENSEED TO
HAUL FUEL TO GET IT THE SERVICE
STATIONS.
JOE BIDEN IS TALKING ABOUT
NATURAL COMPETITION, IF YOU LOOK
AT THE STATES HAVE GOTTEN RID OF
THE EXTRA UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS,
PEOPLE ARE FALLING OFF
UNEMPLOYMENT QUICKER IN THOSE
STATES.
EXPIRES IN SEPTEMBER.
THIS IS AN ECONOMY OR PEOPLE ON
UNEMPLOYMENT BEING PROPPED UP BY
THE GOVERNMENT INTERTENSION.
THE TALK ABOUT 16 CENTS LAST
YEAR, BECAUSE NOBODY CELEBRATED
4th OF JULY LAST YEAR.
16 CENTS WILL BUY YOU 1/20th OF
GAS --
>> ARE YOU UPSET IT WILL COST
$1,000 TO FILL UP YOUR DEFENDER
TANK?
>> AS A FORMER PROFESSIONAL
CHEERLEADER IT'S HARD TO BE
HAPPY.
I KNOW WHAT I DOLL WITH MY 16
CENTS.
I LOOKED UP AT THE ONE YEAR CD.
-- BY THIS TIME NEXT YEAR THAT
15 CENTS WILL BE 22 CENTS.
>> YOU ARE RICH.
>> THE THING ABOUT THE ECONOMY,
IT'S ODDLY DEPENDABLE THAT YOU
CAN TURN IT ON AND OFF LIKE AN
AIR-CONDITIONER ON A HOT DAY.
LAST YEAR WE TURNED THE THING
OFF AND KEPT THE CHILDREN AWAY
FROM THE SWITCHES AND THEN
TURNED IT BACK ON.
IT'S MORE LIKE A SELF-DRIVING
CAR OUR ECONOMY.
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD BE SITTING
IN THE DRIVERS SEAT BUT NOT
TOUCHING ANYTHING.
JUST LET IT G. THE SCARY THING
ABOUT JOE, HE IS NOT BEHIND THE
WHEEL.
SOMEBODY ELSE IS.
>> YES.
HE IS LIKE THE GUY IN ARIZONA
THAT WAS ON HIS PHONE WHILE THE
SELF-DRIVING CAR CRASH